we're now thinking finally oh I've been
waiting so long and I'm really excited
about about solving this problem of area
by using these things called integrals
right integrals are about area but as so
often happens when you develop a tool
right if it's um if it's like a more
sophisticated thing right like we're not
just using area for you as a soldier
we're using calculus where
anti-differentiating we're using the
primitive function to find an area what
you often discover is that the tool is
more powerful than you realized it was
that it actually can do more that you
originally devised now that's both a
good and a bad thing you have to be
careful with it right it's a little bit
like you know saying oh I need to up I
need to slice up some fruit and then you
invent something called a chainsaw and
you're like well this is very good at
slicing up fruit but you can also slice
off your leg okay so integration using
calculus using trig functions is super
powerful it's incredibly powerful it
sets us loose from just triangles and
rectangles and circles and so on but
it's it's dangerous because it can do so
much more
gotta be careful with it so to give you
an example of this let's have a look at
this simple function now if I wanted to
determine and let's just go with some
simple numbers here if I wanted to
determine the area between yeah this is
negative one and which is positive one
okay how would I write if this was
saying you know something simple like y
equals x how would I write the integral
that tells me that defines this area
I'll give you a hint it's not good
morning with this without s for
something under water
very good so one he nice one there and I
read that I even though it's like top to
bottom seems natural right the values
are actually order from bottom to top
because you're we're from small numbers
to large numbers right usually so I read
this is from negative 1 to 1
ok what's the function that I'm
integrating its X and then I've got my
yes there were trees with respect to X
that correspond to that literal with
that we always have and we're
integrating ok now when I have a look at
this I think it's not complicated
ok I just need to know what the
primitive of X is and you signed it
you've done this a few times now right
so what's the function but you
differentiate to leave you with X x
squared are two very good if a power it
goes up and they you to buy ok but I
need to evaluate that and it's beginning
and it's end right so that's why I put
the square box around and I say from
negative 1 to 1 just gonna pause for a
second a bit of language here so we
don't have to keep on saying you know
where it came from proven etc that thing
which you are integrating the thing
you're integrating has a special group
it's called the integrand ok so I'm
gonna start using that way down to refer
to like what's the fee which is actually
be integrated what's the thing I'm
trying to find the area beneath ok ok
sir
so far so good right now I can just
evaluate this right
this means evaluator at one and then
take away what happens when you
evaluated negative one no big deal right
so let's write this out he's the
substitution what squared is just 1 and
then I take you away well what's
negative 1 squared also 1 so that you
come up with this puzzling result that
apparently our area is 0 now it doesn't
look like 0 to me okay it looks pretty
obviously like it takes up some space
ok but here's what I mean by this
integration using this primitive
function right as so is actually more
powerful and more dangerous at the same
time right the area is actually 0 ok uh
at least in accordance with
what the integral tells us because an
integral actually can take a catheter
fact that this area on the left-hand
side here is negative it's beneath the
axis now that's weird right because area
is meant to be a measurement thing so
actually if I wanted to find tell me how
much space this blue thing takes up I
actually have not answered the question
right what evaluated is the integral but
the integrals just a tool to find the
area it actually could do other things
as well like take into its account
negatives okay this is actually really
really useful because if you remember
we've been there that travel graph that
I was talking about before okay
I said you're from here to here and I
said okay what I need to know is like
where you start and where you end and
then that corresponds to down here the
area under a curve do you remember that
now here's the thing if I have down the
bottom right if I had not this kind of
really boring speed time graph right if
I had a graph a bit more like this like
say now if i were comparing between the
same boundaries i think i said one and
three okay if i'm comparing all right so
let's say one bit and three there okay
so this is a speed time graph well you
have a look at this right it's actually
mostly time graph at all because some of
the speed have a look at like what's
happening at our one right some of the
speed is negative now in fact speed just
like like an area is just a it's just a
measurement so you could it'll be
positive in fact this introduces that
I'm sort of teasing what we're gonna
look at next here under motion this is
actually a velocity and it's facing in a
different direction okay so this is a
little bit like okay you know I was
heading south at some point and then I
slowed down and then I started heading
north at some point now if I do that
buddy in exact opposites right exact
opposites if those areas are different
sorry if they're in the same then
essentially what's going to happen is
I'm going to well let's see
I've start somewhere remember it's a
primitive and any of
primitives it doesn't matter which one
so I could start anywhere I like I head
south for some amount of time right
I stopped so that's a stationary point
up here and they were starting north at
a certain time for the same manner time
the same speed what distance have I
traveled now the the total difference
right is zero I end up exactly back
where I started in other words this zero
right the effective distance that I've
traveled well it cancels out right yes
relations are a bit trickier because
when we get to this point here and you
evaluate it's like well if I have a
circle frizzes it's like well well you
take negative one it's like what am I
buddy you're on it's an example negative
1/2 it's like is it this value or is it
this value so you can't actually
evaluate but this has to be a function
it can't be a relation because otherwise
it's like well which one do you want you
have to pick a case all right
so therefore a couple of things to note
right the first thing is integrals that
use the primitive function right they
take into account they use right an area
under the axis registers is negative
which is not that difficult to confirm
if for instance I just wanted to work
out just part of the left right how do I
work out just that part of it yeah I'd
start at negative one and I am at zero
right and I'd still keep going
I'd go X square sorry X I'm integrating
greater X DX right there's the integrand
they're my primitive is x squared on to
right from negative one to zero okay
careful careful how do I evaluate this
what's the extra three what's the FMA is
your on to take away one on shoes
there's the negative area area beneath
the axis is probably a better way to say
it okay so you can see just by crunching
the numbers right integrals are more
powerful than just like ah tell me what
the areas of these triangles are okay if
the question was tell me the actual area
you can't just simply evaluate this
because you get out something which is
meaningless this area is not actually
zero okay how would I do it okay so I've
got a couple of choices right
and there's I'm gonna I'm gonna unpack
these all formally laid up but just for
this particular example right I could
say this area over here being beneath
the axis I'll label it and you might
like to label it as well I'm going to
call this area one and I'll call this
one area 2 okay I'm giving them
different names because I'm treating
them separately
ones negative and ones positive so I
have to deal with them in different ways
right I would say area one is not the
integral from negative one to zero in
fact it is negative the integral from
negative one to zero right because I can
see it's beneath the axis so what I want
is the area then I have to slap a minus
sign on the front okay and then
everything proceeds as it did before I'm
still going to get the same number out
so it's negative negative 1/2 and so
that triangle there has the area of
uh-huh right I could say in the same way
well area two that's above the axis no
problems right so if you're above the
axis then that area and the integral
going to the premium are exactly the
same thing right they're identical so I
don't have to apply any minus side to
the front I just go from zero to one
right and there'd be exactly the same
way I'm going to get a half so then the
total area the total area is actually
equal to well one plus the other and
that looks a little more in a consonant
with the actual
that I draw it's a positive value after
all okay